in leuk betreiben swisscom das
eidgenössische departement für
verteidigung und private unternehmen aus
dem umfeld des amerikanischen
geheimdienstes einen antennen park für
satelliten kommunikation zwischen der
schweiz und im ausland
[Musik]
im jahr 2000 wurde dieser strategische
ort das bevorzugte einfallstor für die
nsa um die kommunikation der gesamten
welt aus zu spüren
welches spiel spielt die schweiz die
schweiz ist nicht neutral
wenn es um die geheimdienste geht das
ist klar
sie brachten es für diese kooperation
es sind ja nie wieder mut war die
regelung aber das ist ein
charakteristikum der schweizerischen
aussenpolitik das nicht immer mehr
gemacht
[Musik]
mai sein neues wünschen im fernsehen bei
bundespräsident adolf ogi eine
strategisch wichtige baustelle für die
schweizer nachrichtendienste 1
sie befindet sich im wallis in leuk seit
1974 betreiben die ptt und das
eidgenössische departement für
verteidigung dort einen antennen park
für die satellitenkommunikation zwischen
der schweiz und dem ausland
die zivil- und militäranlage
funktioniert 25 jahre lang wunderbar in
perfekter verschwiegenheit
dann gerät sie plötzlich ins rampenlicht
[Applaus]
der jahrhundert wechsel ist ein
wendepunkt die antennen von leuk sind
das herzstück des schweizerischen
projekts internationale
satellitenkommunikation zivile wie
militärische abzufangen
das system heißt onyx im großen und
ganzen ist es der sehr kleine
schweizerische bruder des
angelsächsischen spionagenetzes die
entstehung von onyx fällt zeitlich mit
der umstrukturierung der schweizer
nachrichtendienst zusammen
im herbst 2000 gips viscom ehemals ptt
seine antennen überraschend an wer es
darauf
das us-amerikanische unternehmen
arbeitet für die navy und das
us-verteidigungsministerium am 15
november 2000 sind die verträge
unterzeichnet sie bereiten der politik
und den schweizer agenten sorge von nun
an zähle zu den neuen mietern washington
[Musik]
schokologo je koordinierte damals die
informationen aus den verschiedenen
schweizer nachrichtendiensten
[Musik]
die sitcom europa in bern muss der
sprecher adolf ogi gute miene zum bösen
spiel machen
[Musik]
ich hatte bei dieser operation
persönlich sehr gute gefühle
denn da immer auch
meine persönlichen 2 oswald sigg hat
keinerlei ahnung von den aktivitäten der
schweiz agenten denn innerhalb des
departements für verteidigung kann der
nachrichtendienst damals schalten und
walten wie er will
sein budget seine einsatzkräfte seien
modus operandi sind geheim
[Applaus]
nun kann cambell gießt öl ins feuer
der englische journalist untersucht seit
jahrzehnten internationale geheimdienst
tätigkeiten enthüllt 1988 die existenz
des angelsächsischen spionagenetzes
[Applaus]
er veröffentlicht im jahr 2000 auf
ersuchen des europäischen parlaments
einen explosiven bericht doing kann
cambell betont darin dass das
schweizerische onyx programm mit seinem
großen bruder echelon gemeinsame sache
machen könnte amerikanische agenten
hätten den leuten dann einen
zweitwohnsitz
das schließt der partie das seht ihr
eine burg ist in die maschine
das wissen die debatte nicht klar was
nicht bedeutet dass die schweiz nicht
mit den großen ausländischen
nachrichtendiensten kooperiert
so wie es ist sie projizieren
kollaboration auf eine überraschung wie
die wartung von der batterien aus dem
ende
[Musik]
die satelliten übermitteln massenweise
daten funksignale sprachkommunikation
internet fax und fernsehen
aber wie sollte washington von leuk
ausspionieren ganz einfach bei einem
anruf über satelliten verbindung sendet
eine parabolantenne ein signal zu einem
rolle satelliten in den weltraum dieser
rolle satellit sendet das selbe signal
zurück zur erde
aber mit einer anderen frequenz das
signal wird von einer parabolantenne b
empfangen
es genügt wenn die abhör stationen der
nachrichtendienste ihre parabolantennen
auf diese satelliten richten und die
verwendeten frequenzen einstellen um den
kommunikationsfluss mitzuhören
offiziell werden die antennen von
signalhorn in läuft für zivile zwecke
verwendet aber spionieren sie für die
amerikaner
das ist der streitpunkt bei dieser
ungewöhnlichen gemeinsamen nutzung mit
dem departement für verteidigung
[Musik]
die unheimliche geschichte von lloyd ist
mit wäre es dann noch nicht zu ende
bis februar 2012 wechselt der eigentümer
dreimal alle machen sie geschäfte mit
washington signalhorn kam zuletzt die
luxemburgische firma betreibt heute 25
der etwa 30 antennen der anlage
das departement für verteidigung mietet
sie für militärische zwecke
offiziell gibt es keinerlei geschäfte
zwischen der armee und signalhorn die
beiden mieter teilen sich lediglich die
wasser und strom kosten so das
eidgenössische departement für
verteidigung
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wenn man auch davon ausgeht dass
eigentlich der schweizerische
geheimdienst sowieso mit verschiedenen
westlichen geheimdiensten und auch mit
den us amerikanischen geheimdiensten eng
zusammenarbeitet und deshalb ist das gar
nicht ein konkurrent oder ein feind
sondern ein partner in anführungszeichen
und dann entsprechen diesmal natürlich
auch nicht mehr kritisch
die soli kollaboration und richtig war
es theoretisch hat die schweiz ein
abkommen unterschrieben ist die
zusammenarbeit in formeller oder sogar
erzwungen was gibt die schweiz
und was bekommt sie dafür
[Musik]
die muss bis 2013 klärt adwords snowden
über das ausmaß amerikanischer spionage
in der ganzen welt auf diese enthüllung
verbietet ihren einen zentralen akteur
der antennen von leuk swisscom
vergessen wir nicht dass die
eidgenossenschaft noch immer 51 prozent
der anteile an dem anbieter hält
swisscom gewährleistet die ausrüstung
den betrieb und den schutz der
kommunikation die firma ist gleichzeitig
ein zulieferer des departements für
verteidigung parlament hat swisscom
einen unheimlichen gut wählen
ich habe das selbst erlebt an
verschiedensten lobby veranstaltungen
swisscom ist unheimlich gut organisiert
weiß welche parlamentarier was denken
und hat die nötigen kontakte macht auch
geschickt das lobbying sie machen ihre
arbeit gut und entsprechend hat swisscom
einen riesigen einfluss ihren ich denke
dass spielt mit auch eine rolle weshalb
es wenig kritische fragen gibt
welche rolle hat swisscom gespielt auf
nachfrage hin wollte jens alder bis 2010
geschäftsführer dieses kapitel seiner
beruflichen laufbahn nicht noch einmal
aufschlagen
bruchstücke eine antwort ergeben sich
aus den snowden dokumenten
genauer gesagt aus dem programm die nsa
hat eine interaktive echtzeit karte des
weltweiten internets mit dem sie mit
leichtigkeit in die computersysteme der
ganzen welt eindringen und sie
kontrollieren kann
das nennt sich treffern ab sie versorgt
die karte mit daten aus geheim servern
in sogenannten unfreiwilligen
rechenzentren
das heißt die betreiber wissen nichts
von deren existenz oder kennen nicht
ihre wirkliche identität in europa hat
die nsa die geheim server in sechs
ländern stationiert polen deutschland
ukraine lettland dänemark und russland
die blauen pfeile zeigen die großen
datenströme aus unserer internet und
mobilfunk kommunikation
damit kann die nsa computer angriffe
planen und schwachstellen ausnutzen
die zentralen knotenpunkte in rot stehen
für diejenigen die für den
amerikanischen geheimdienst und seine
partner von interesse sind
das heißt die nsa ist in der lage sich
zugriff zu diesen firmen netzwerken zu
verschaffen und beobachtet welche daten
dort im umlauf sind unter den roten
knotenpunkten swisscom
balthasar glättli ist in bern einer der
wenigen parlamentarier der sich mit dem
thema auskennt und so stellt er fragen
die für ärger sorgen
fünf jahre nachdem snowden enthüllungen
weitet der grün aus zürich noch immer
auf antworten was machte eigentlich die
schweiz was spielte eigentlich die
schweiz für eine rolle weshalb ist der
bundesrat nicht kritik kritischer
weshalb hat der bundesrat die
ermittlungen aufgenommen oder erst viel
zu spät ermittlungen bewilligt diese
fragen fielen dann unter den tisch
der ehemalige bundesrat adolf ogi heute
pensionär in seinem grundstück in
kandersteg äußert sich nicht öffentlich
die sache mit den antennen bleibt
sensibel
sie vermischt die interessen eines
unternehmens mit denen der nationalen
sicherheit der berner ist an die
schweigepflicht gebunden
seine ohren hat washington in seinem
domizil im wallis doch am rande des lac
léman hat es sein hauptquartier bezogen
im internationalen gen betreiben die usa
ihr gewaltiges ab hörsystem eine riesige
spielwiese für den agenten adwords
snowden bevor er zu einem der größten
whistleblower wurde
[Musik]